- ONLY YOU CAN PREVENT FIRES
IN FORESTS.
[applause]
[English accent] IN THE ROYAL
SHAKESPEARE COMPANY,
WE USED TO CALL THAT
A CATCHPHRASE.
- WELCOME TO OUR HUMBLE PARK,
MR. FLAMEY.
- NOTHING HUMBLE ABOUT IT,
OLD BOY.
THIS IS MOTHER NATURE
IN ALL HER GLORY.
WHY, THERE, THE MAJESTIC TREES,
A SPARROW OVER THERE,
AND THERE IS A HILLBILLY NUDE
FROM THE WAIST DOWN,
HIGH ON METHAMPHETAMINES,
EATING PAGES FROM THE BIBLE.
- HEY, FLAMEY, LOVE YOUR WORK!
- DELIGHTFUL.
- HI!
MY NAME IS STEVE.
I AM YOUR BIGGEST FAN.
- FLATTERED, MY GOOD MAN,
FLATTERED.
AND THIS MUST BE
YOUR LOVELY GIRLFRIEND.
- SHE'S NOT MY GIRLFRIEND.
I MEAN, IF I DATED EVERYBODY
I MASTURBATED TO,
I'D BE DATING YOU, FLAMEY.
- I THINK I'M GOING
TO LIKE YOU, STEVEN.
- REALLY?
I ACTUALLY MET YOU
A LONG TIME AGO, AT THE OPENING
OF A WINN-DIXIE.
- I DON'T RECALL.
- I JUST WANTED YOU
TO SIGN THIS ALBUM.
IS THERE ANY WAY
YOU COULD DO IT NOW?
- MY APOLOGIES, STEVEN,
BUT MY BUSY SCHEDULE
ONLY ALLOWS ME
TO SIGN BREASTS.
- WELL, I'VE GOT QUITE
THE PAIR OF--
- WOMEN'S BREASTS.
- ISN'T HE GREAT?
- JUST DON'T TAKE YOUR EYES
OFF HIM FOR A SECOND!
IF HE'S NOT AT THAT OPENING,
IT'S YOUR ASS, STEVE!
AND WHATEVER YOU DO,
DON'T LET HIM DRINK!
- WHY NOT?
- TRUST ME, DON'T!
- SHOW ME TO YOUR CABIN
AT ONCE, STEVEN.
IF I DON'T PINCH A LOAF SOON,
IT'S GOING TO PINCH ME BACK!
A FLAMEY THE BEAR TOILET.
VERY INTERESTING.
I'VE NEVER SHIT
IN MY OWN MOUTH BEFORE.
- THAT'S NOTHING!
I'VE GOT "TRIVIAL PURSUIT:
FLAMEY EDITION,"
AND YOUR AUTHORIZED SEX TAPE
WITH LIZA MINNELLI.
- OH, LIZA!
SHE HAD A CROTCH LIKE
A GIANT BOWL OF TARANTULAS.
SPEAKING OF ALCOHOLICS,
DO YOU HAVE ANYTHING HERE
TO DRINK, MY GOOD MAN?
- UM, I'M SO SORRY,
BUT MY BOSS SAID--
[laughs nervously]
AND THIS IS CRAZY--
HE SAID I COULDN'T
LET YOU DRINK.
- THAT'S TOO BAD.
I WAS HOPING WE COULD TOAST
TO OUR NEW FRIENDSHIP.
- FRIENDSHIP? FRIENDS?
YOU AND I ARE FRIENDS?
- OF COURSE WE ARE, MY BOY.
- YOU KNOW WHAT?
IF YOU PROMISE NOT
TO TELL ANYONE,
I HAVE A LITTLE SOMETHING I WAS
SAVING FOR A SPECIAL OCCASION.
- TO OUR FRIENDSHIP!
UNH!